If you're in a healthy relationship with a man,
can you stitch this video and talk about it?
Any chance I get to brag on my husband,
I have to take it.
So if you are struggling, um,
in the dating arena,
I just wanna tell you that there is good men
still out there.
They do exist.
I met my husband through mutual friends of ours,
and since the day I met him,
we've been completely inseparable.
And I've never really felt that way about anyone else.
Let me tell you,
I have kissed many frogs to get to my prince. Okay, I.
Manchilds, okay?
They are not.
They're not even worthy to be called men,
half of them.
And so, ah, ha, ha.
Meeting my husband,
he was different
than any of the guys that I've previously been with.
My husband is very soft spoken.
He is very kind.
He is very selfless.
The amount of miles my husband goes for just me,
not even our daughter,
just for me.
That is speaks volumes of his character.
This man still gives me butterflies.
He still gives me butterflies to this day.
Like, anytime he's telling me he's coming home,
I get butterflies
because I am just so excited to see him.
One time, um,
through my entire marriage,
that has really stuck with me
was how he treated me postpartum.
Now, if you ever been pregnant,
you've had a baby,
you know how vulnerable postpartum is.
I had Severe postpartum anxiety,
like, really bad.
And then I had a little bit,
I think, of postpartum depression.
Um, but my husband,
man, he was my absolute rock through that.
You know, I would wake up
breastfeeding my child in the middle of the night,
he would wake up, too,
and there's nothing he can do.
He. He could sleep.
You know, he should sleep,
honestly, with the line of his work.
Um, but he would just sit there and rub my back
and tell me I'm doing a good job,
that I'm a good mom.
When I was nursing, he would.
I wasn't able to, like,
eat with my hands.
He sat there and fed me some stew out of a bowl,
and I just. I don't know.
It's just little,
small acts like that are just huge.
He is so patient with me, okay,
that. That alone is Equality,
because I can drive my spouse nuts,
but he is so patient with me.
He's so gentle with me.
Um, he's never harsh.
He never speaks harshly to me,
and if he does,
he's very quick to apologize.
It's very rare occasion that he's
ever said anything harsh to me.
The thing I love most about our marriage
is the ability that we have to laugh together,
which I swear
is the key to marriage.
If you cannot laugh about a really bad situation,
um, together,
I. I don't know. It's.
Laughter is the best medicine in marriage.
That Is my opinion on that.
I truly can say that he is my best friend.
And there is good men out there.
Do not get discouraged.
There is good men out there.
I promise you.
Um, look in your local churches,
because that's where a lot of them are.